[Music]
fighting the pandemic
could become a battle against debt
lockdowns have halted the flow of cash
to workers and companies
forcing governments to step in
we need to provide more immediate relief
for working families
and businesses now now
countries rich and poor are burning
through vast amounts of money
but it's all on loan they're taking on
dead like never before
and could be setting a dangerous
precedent
[Music]
it'll leave younger generations to foot
the bill
and their financial futures already look
plague
economists argue we'll have to dig deep
to get out of this crisis
but the pandemic's not the only guilty
party the pace of global public debt
accumulation has increased by
tens of trillions of dollars over the
past few years
vast sums are being spent to bail out
ravaged economies
hundreds of billions of euros in germany
in india
in china and in the united states
trillions governments have
to borrow most of this money but who
will pay the debt back
today's elderly or today's young
much public debt only comes due decades
later
that means today's young will carry the
can in many countries
there's already a shortage of jobs and
training opportunities
higher taxes and spending cuts are quite
likely in the future
so are today's millennials the main
losers in the coronavirus crisis
[Music]
not necessarily they might also stand to
benefit
if investment is focused on shaping the
future
education digitalization
environmental protection
[Music]
if firms are kept going through the
crisis jobs should become available
again
holders of government bonds should
eventually get paid out
today's young will inherit public debt
but some of them will also inherit
government bonds
so members of the same generation will
be paying
each other back
if an economy grows strongly repaying
debt won't be a huge problem
protracted crises by contrast would be a
disaster
inflation bankruptcy mass unemployment
would be much worse for coming
generations
than inheriting a pile of public debt
lori parsons is british academy
post-doctoral research fellow at royal
holloway university of london
what do you reckon dangerous precedent
or a sound
way of funding the recovery
well i think in answering that question
the first thing we have to consider is
the distinction between public debt
and private debt as an individual might
hold now this is something that often
gets conflated in public discourse
but nevertheless it's a very important
distinction to consider when we think
about the recovery and debt terms from
this crisis
now whereas an individual who takes out
a loan on a credit card for example has
fixed terms of interest and repayment
a country which takes out debt takes out
loans usually in its own currency
this has huge implications for the way
in which that debt
is repaid for example a currency which
takes on debt has
influenced both directly by the issuing
of government bonds and also indirectly
via influence over
the central bank which can change
interest rates and
also the supply of money so a country
which takes on debt for whatever reasons
actually has quite a significant amount
of control
retained over the way in which they
repay it
and actually this means that it's
possible to take a number of strategies
to that repayment and there are some
examples quite recently one of the
positive things is that the 2008 great
recession actually gave us some examples
of better and poorer practice in that
respect
right here in the uk for example we're
an example of of not doing terribly well
because of the huge emphasis on
austerity cutting public services and
cutting back as much debt as possible
too quickly which is now generally
thought to have
impeded the recovery from that 2008
crash
so i hope that in the wake of the cover
19
crisis we see a different strategy more
broadly accepted and one in which
we see a broader uh push towards towards
growth and and widely shared prosperity
rather than
emphasizing that debt in itself is it
one that's working in both developed and
developing countries
well the important thing to think i
think about um
about the difference between the global
north and the global south countries
like germany and the uk
versus countries such as india
bangladesh
cambodia is that in many cases those
debts aren't held in their national
currency so that puts a very different
spin on things essentially
so whereas we are able to control the
terms of our debt in a country in the
global south you tend to
hold debt for example in u.s dollars or
widely available
uh currencies such as pound sterling and
as a result of that that means you don't
have that control over the terms by
which you repay that debt
now this means that you have to repay it
even if it is economically extremely
damaging to do so
and so this is by no means a new issue
it's something which has been going on
for a very long time but it is likely to
be accelerated in a very significant
way by the debts of crude as a result of
the coveted 19 crisis
just to give you some idea of the extent
to which this already goes on
just the interest payments alone from
banks in new york and london have
amounted to around 4.2 trillion
in payments from the global south to
global north and that is already
considerably more than the total sum of
development aid spending so in many ways
we have a situation where as a result of
debt
it's the global south developing the
global north rather than the other way
around
um so a lot of this depends upon what
the dollar is doing what the us economy
is doing
let's look at the total public debt in
the u.s as a percentage of gross
domestic product
from the global financial crisis up
until this crisis
the graph gets scary how are we going to
keep up or how is the us going to keep
up
well i mean the us has been the holders
of one of the major currencies in the in
the world has a huge advantage in that
respect it can do a lot to influence
the ways in which it repays that debt
and it's important of course to
consider not only a single graph in
which you're looking at debt but also
the wider context
if your public health response involves
people staying at home
uh if you think that their workplaces
are too dangerous and that's going to
influence the spreading of the virus
in places like that then if you want
them to actually stay at home then you
simply have to pay them in some respects
so and that's what of course been done
in different way to european countries
but through the same basic idea with the
fiscal stimulus checks that have been
written
in the u.s so as a result of those
necessary provisions which are
absolutely essential if you want people
to stay home if that is your
public health response then we see these
huge increases of debt
but nevertheless you have to consider
the counterfactual whereby
all of these businesses and all of those
individuals were unable to
have any income or the businesses were
unable to maintain
any of their any of their ongoing uh
financial commitments and as a result of
that when you wake up from the covet
crisis
you find yourself essentially emerging
into something of an economic wasteland
so that's what all of this money has
been in the service of
it's essentially an investment now in
future prosperity
whereby we have the same economic tools
and landscaping infrastructures
to rebound to that position that we were
in in early 2020
and what happens if we don't wake up
from this anytime soon if we're forced
to stay home a lot longer
if another pandemic hits right after
this one
well i think of course it's a problem
that we all hope not to have to face
i think however it's important to retain
a certain degree of optimism over the
future
especially in relation to our economic
behavior of course the
attitudes that we take into this
recovery will be hugely important
in allowing us to rebound strongly and
return to something like
the normality which we knew in early
2020 so
optimism i hope towards the latter part
of this year will be the order of the
day
larry parsons university of london thank
you
it's that part of the show where we put
your questions to our science
correspondent derek williams
what are the chances on a long-haul
flight of contracting covet 19 on the
plane
i haven't been on a plane for over a
year now but i've heard from family
and friends and colleagues just how
unnerving flying has become especially
on long haul flights where people can be
cooped up together for
for upwards of 15 hours at a time
it's become an activity somewhat fraught
with uncertainty
since since the science we have on
transmission
in airplanes is still pretty meager um
that's because you can't run a tightly
controlled experiment
involving an infectious possibly deadly
pathogen
on a long commercial flight instead
you have to see whether outbreaks might
have originated on one
and then extrapolate backwards which is
always a tricky business that's what a
study from new zealand
did with a flight that arrived there
from dubai
in late september now passengers who fly
to new zealand at the moment have to
quarantine for two weeks
on arrival and they're tested for the
virus twice
during that period um seven out of 86
passengers from the dubai flight tested
positive during that quarantine and
because
most of them had tested negative before
takeoff
the scientists believed the indicators
were very strong that the infection
had happened in flight they based their
hypothesis
on a range of data some of it
epidemiologic
but also the in-flight seating plan when
the symptoms began
and the genome sequences of viruses
taken from each of the passengers
perhaps the most compelling evidence for
me
was proximity um how close the people
who ended up infected
sat in relationship to one another on
the plane
that row of four dots by the way was a
family
and and the scientists thought the
original transmitter
was one of the people represented by a
blue dot
um all in all i found the study very
convincing that transmission
on a long-haul flight can happen but we
still don't know
how rarely or or how often it happens or
or what factors exactly might contribute
to it
[Music]
you